all right welcome back next up we have
Ahmed Ahmed why don't you tell us a
little bit of what you do sure said my
name is Ahmed I'm a dual core programs
engineer at Google cloud I work on
Google kubernetes engine Candido project
and so on
awesome so you've been working in
kubernetes for quite awhile you know
I've been following your career what's
one of the biggest pain points that you
see in the kubernetes ecosystem right
now yeah so my primary audience is the
developers and I think the Olbers deal
with these command lines who's what not
a lot so I'm seeing that in some you
know inner iteration circles there's a
lot of like developer cycles wasted if
you will that is like going towards just
you know these simple things around
tools like you've control so I like to
develop tools and shortcuts around
control that's kind of my personal
passion okay and coop control is kind of
like one of the main ways in which
people submit everything to kubernetes
right so what's what are some of the
problems around you know coop controller
where can we expand it or where are
people hitting pain points so there's
like an entire open source special
interest group sig CLI in kubernetes
this dealing with that problem one of
the areas that they propose improvement
is that no they they cannot possibly
implement everything that people want so
they wanted to provide some extension
capability around cube cuddle so they
basically said hey why don't we provide
an plugin system so that people can
write their own progress programs around
cube cut' oh and they can invoke them
through the cue cuddle command line okay
have you written any plugins yourself
yeah I've been playing with some players
myself one thing that actually I've been
working on is a plugin manager called
khru so this is basically like Bri one
Mac OS and this is K so crew so there's
a lot of cool team there if you can
catch this okay kre w not cre w yes is
this right so this is a project that
we've been working on at GU cloud the
sexually this project was started by my
intern this summer
Luke Pritchard and his album yo and
github so he was super cool guy and we
started this project called crew so
while crew does is it's a plugin manager
for cube cutter so if you want to
discover plugins he's going to install
plugins you go to Chrome installed click
on to your computer
then from there you can discover new
plugins and just bring them to your
machine and then use it with KUKA so I
assume it's open source yes this is open
source we haven't announced it a lot I
guess this is probably the biggest
announcement so far you hated her first
people yeah and then right now we're in
the process of talking to 60 Li -
perhaps tonight this project to Korea's
open source committee and make it a non
Google project all right well so let
let's get technical for a bit and says
they announced this how does crew find
plugins is there a registry github how
do we find them so we have a central
registry on github W I'll break
currently anyone who do all those
plugins that we just need those people
to package their plugins into say some
like guitar ball or a zip file and then
they write a manifest file describing
how the plugins should be installed and
then they submit this player manifest
I'll file to the central repository that
we have and then from there everyone can
discover Dells players so if you're like
shopping for some let's say a plug-in -
via the logs you don't have to go to
like Google surgeon like search like
what are the plugins that I can use so
you can just come to Crewe and search
for blogs and then we'll show you all
the plugins that are about log really
well so let's go let's go back let's say
crew doesn't exist
yeah how do I get a plug-in into coop
cuddle today without crew yeah well
first of all you need to find that a
plugin that you're looking for exists I
think that's one of the biggest problems
and that's one of the primary reasons
that we start a crew discoverability is
one of the largest problems out there so
after you find the plug-in you need to
download to your package and then you
need to name it in a specific place so
let's say you have a plugin called food
so you need to name it cubic RL - food
and then put it into somewhere in your
path and if you put it in your path and
everything is good you can invoke it by
saying cube cuddle space food so that's
how do you saw and set up playing that
sounds like a lot of magic so imagine
you're installing like 10 15 plugins and
you have to keep them up-to-date because
you know all these plugins will have
newer versions so that's another thing
that crew Souls really well if you
manage the plug-in life cycle and we can
bring the updates automatically you
basically say hey
QC TL crow update and we basically
outplayed all these plugins if they have
newer versions awesome so this thing
sounds really cool one where can people
get more information and to what's
what's the future look like for crew
yeah so people can go to github.com
slash google container - slash crew with
k feel free to try it out I think we're
on something like version 0.2 this is so
very early days so far it's been working
fine be aware I think almost 20 plugins
by the way there are not a lot of
plugins here so we also want people to
like think about plugin ideas and what
to develop but also you want to donate
to Bernie's project so we want it to be
a craze six year live project that
perhaps someday eventually rolls into
coop Corral and so that you can just say
cubicle plugins installed food right so
that we want to go to a world where
these sort of things are easily
discoverable and manageable awesome
thank you very much of it
[Music]